مشاهدينا الكرام هذه المسيره التي يصفها
الفلسطينيون بالاستفزازيه بدات عام
1968 بعد بعد عام واحد من احتلال الشق
الشرقي من المدينه المقدسه بقرار من حكومه
الاحتلال الذي كان يوافق يوما في التقويم
العبري وهذا اليوم يتحرك مع التقويم
الميلادي شيئا فشيئا هذه مدينه القدس التي
تقع في وسط الاراضي الفلسطينيه في غربي
النهر الاردن او ما يعرف بفلسطين
التاريخيه اذا ما دخلنا اكثر الى هذه
المنطقه فنحن نتحدث عن البلده القديمه من
القدس التي نشاهدها على الخريطه هذه
البلده القديمه من القدس المحتله والتي
تتشكل من هذا المربع الذي يضم حوالي او
مساحته اقل من واحد كيلو متر مربع كما
نشاهد على الخريطه ابرز ابواب البلده
القديمه هو باب العمود والذي نشاهد منه
الصور المبا التي تاتينا هناك والتي كانت
عنده قبل قليل نجوان سمري كما نشاهد على
الخريطه هذه او على الشاشه هذه صور باب
العمود في المنطقه الشماليه من البلده
القديمه كما نشاهد على الشاشه من هنا هنا
سيتجمع المستوطنون الاسرائيليون الذين
ياتون من كل احياء المدينه مدينه القدس
يتحركون من كل احياء مدينه القدس باتجاه
البلده القديمه وتحديدا باتجاه باب العمود
كما نشاهد على الخريطه يريد المستوطنون
الدخول الى المدينه القدس من جهه باب
العمود
والوصول الى منطقه حائط البراق في الجهه
الغربيه من المسجد الاقصى المبارك كما
نشاهد على الشاشه هذه النقطه التي يريد
المستوطنون التجمع فيها ويريدون ادخال او
الدخول بمسيره رقصه الاعلام عبر هذا الخط
لماذا يصر المستوطنون على الدخول من هذا
المسار لان البلده القديمه في القدس تنق
الى عده احياء تاريخيا الحي الاسلامي هو
الحي الكبير الذي يضم المسجد الاقصى
المبارك كما نشاهد على الخريطه والذي يشكل
الشق الشرقي من البلده القديمه بالاضافه
الى حي النصارى الذي يضم الشقه الغربي يضم
كنيسه القيامه لهذه المنطقه وايضا
بالاضافه الى الحي الارمني في هذه المنطقه
الجنوبيه الغربيه وحي المغاربه او ما بت
يعرف الان بالحي اليهودي بعد ان احتله
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عام 67 وطرد كل
الفلسطينيين الموجودين في هذه المنطقه وفي
حي المغاربه يقع باب المغاربه ويقع حاله
البراق من هنا يريد المستوطنون الدخول في
هذا المسار لاستفزاز الفلسطينيين الذين
يشكلون الغالبيه العظمى من سكان الحي
الاسلامي لذلك
قررت سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان يغلق
كل الفلسطينيون محالهم في هذه المنطقه
المحلي التجاريه في هذه المنطقه لكي
يتجنبوا الاحتكاك مع المستوطنين الذين
يدخلون في هذه المسيره الاستفزازيه من
عشرات الالاف بعد ذلك او بالتزامن مع هذه
المسيره كما ذكر احمد هزيمه تتواصل عمليات
اقتحام المسجد الاقصى المبارك هذا هو
المسجد الاقصى المبارك كما نشاهد على
الخريطه
وهذا هذا هو المسجد الاقصى المبارك 144
دونم والذي يقع في الشق الجنوبي الشرقي من
البلده القديمه في القدس اقتحامات
المستوطنين لمسجد الاقصى المبارك تتواصل
ويدخل المستوطنون من باب المغاربه يقفون
في هذه النقطه يؤدون صلوات تلموديه امام
بين مسجد قبه الصخره والمسجد القبلي في
هذه المنطقه وهذه المنطقه التي عاده ما
تشهد المناوشات مع الفلسطينيين ثم يتواصل
مسار الاقتحامات نحو الشمال يلتف
المستوطنون الى الجهه الشماليه من مسجد
قبه الصخره داخل المسجد الاقصى مبارك
ويلتفون نحو المنطقه الغربيه ثم جنوبا ثم
من باب السلسله يخرجون هذا هو مسار
الاقتحامات اليوميه للمسجد الاقصى المبارك
الذي شاهدناها قبل قليل وتتحدث عن احمد
هزيم وعن بالمناسبه احمد هزيم يقف في
منطقه جبل الزيتون في هذه المنطقه المطله
على المسجد الاقصى المبارك ونجوان سمري
تقف في هذه المنطقه منطقه باب العمود مسار
مسيره الاعلام الس